right to branstrom with a long pass up the far
side of kubal down the boards with teraso can't
get there ahead of KET off now they work it
free play to front just out of the reach of
teraso now a shot the score Ricochet in off
KET off and the S get a lucky Road bounce to
make a one- [Applause] nothing we're going
to show you the goal Bernard Docker with the
blast but let's take a look how the movement
is for Jacob marks and he looks okay there he
makes a nice save and unfortunately for KET
off playing his first game that's not going
to be all that memorable how deflection
off the goalie off his left knee goes
in so Anderson on the near side now with a play
back to weager over over to cadri Zer chopped
away from him by Sanderson wh the head not out
stolen Sherry takes a look scores top Corner
1-1 certainly scoring chances and that's
what the Senators do Puck along the boards
and watch their shot by Z that is perfectly
placed pass his ninth of the season and what
a shot for Corp pasalo I mean that's a tough
shot to face early on in the game and slowly
to his own line ahead to sharing goich swing in
wide puts the puck in off the boards shabas back
stolen hu in front sharing goic stop rebound
weager couldn't get the shot through another
turnover and a great chance for Sharon bich gat
for Calgary late in the period way down the board
fed across the CH shop block CH again gets it
right back put it in front stopped by Marsh
that one timer by Greg again given away teras
senko back at the line that shot deflected off
bodies marks down they score finally put home
by kubalik one point6 seconds to go that shift
was a minute 20 for the group markson made a
couple of good saves including that one off
Greg now there's turn over again Puck's going
to come to CH on the flank he gets it right
on net and there's Greg right in the crease and
that's KUB that comes by we're going to have to
see the ice is a good goal yeah they're going to
say rasas Anderson had taken Greg into the goal
tender settled down by Joseph he's checked LOL
kicks the puck in front of the goal there's a
pass to Sher gold scores great work by Leno nice
pass by hubero and Sher goic ties the game of
[Applause] [Music] [Applause] two all right
turnovers have hurt both teams and he's going
to try and spin around Spin and lyol does
a fantastic job of knocking the fck off the
plate gets in front to hubero and quickly to
Sharon goic what an individual effort by lyol
though to kick that puck out front to hubero
but BR kachu Josh Norris Shabbat jaru in the
circle drops it off batterson's pass here's jaru
tips it back but Chuck scores on the power play
on the setup from giru he goes top shelf and
it's 3-2 Ottawa and me and my big mouth what
did I say earlier this period Rick it's been
pretty Qui yeah it's not very often you say
he puts his sends up by a goal really good Puck
movement here by the centers and they move it
around a little bit I love jiru he just never
gives up on the puck and then gets it right
out to kachu and watch how kachu just moves
a little bit to his left creates a bit of an
opening harder for lyol to get that stick in
the passing lane and then his 17th goal of
the Season puts Ottawa back on top 3-2 with 721
left in the second period nzim kadrian looks to
answer over to posil got a shot away stopped
by Corpus nice job by pospas will take that
pass gets to Center and plays the buck in
Coleman on it finds backman backman feeds it
over D with a shot stopped by coroso well out
of the crease to make that save makes a pass
shoot stop rebound Corell fights It Up played
back in front and it's backhanded out by Co
jro Flames win the draw Hanahan feeds it
over posil back to Hanahan he to chase
it down the boards cut to the circle back
head scores Noah Hanan on the backand and
it's tie of [Music] three us it we've talked
a lot about it watch posil just sort of sneak
out to the top of the by the Blue Line
get that pass and then Noah hanin just
with traffic in front on his backand and
you can see zeri right in front of Corpus
Alo that's why it doesn't even have to be
a hard shot just Elevate that was perfectly
exec theu the Norris he'll SWAT it into the
zone and get Chase marks him out to play it
Anderson look out dangerous play marks
gets back just the time pu still loose
Flames clear the Zone a good save play ahead to
Zer stolen turned over teraso backand wide Greg
pass in front where's the Pucket in the crease
red Away by had of the first shot hit the post
bman on the four check rrom dods two hits and
made a pass but xer steals it back with some
good work here's cadri Hanahan looking for
a second breaks the stick turns it's score
broken stick turned to into a pass to Coleman
and he gives Calgary their first lead of the
night and Rusty likes that one yes he does
well how do you like that watch Coleman go
to the front which he does so often Senator
Jo turns it over here's a broken stick and
it goes ever so slowly to Coleman and he just
he has a wherewithal to know that the golender
is out of the crease and he's got to get away
from the front of the net good play by Coleman
if Coleman just jams It swatted Away by
Cham but it goes right to weager and now
Sharon goich winding up out of his own Zone
ahead to cadri down the wing NZ cadri in goes
down it's Hanahan shoots off the leg it's
goore second of the night for Sher goic 53
Calgary well that's a second of this
evening for Sharon Govich how about
Noah Hanahan in the third period
alone this a beautiful exit by the
Flames Sharon govic gets it to cadri and
he pulls up spots Noah Hanan the good hard
shot hits ch right onto the sck Sharon
goich but what a period by Noah hanifan
wow and cadri should get the second assist
on that play so grab that puck that's that
across back L ahead to Coleman with
the empty net can't get the shot
away now it's stolen by backlin here's pin
scores no doubt about that one Blake Coleman
with the the empty n that makes it 6-3 Calgary
and he turned the puck over here's the first
chance where Coleman is looking for the empty n
watch sta right here all sorts of time to make
a play trying to throw it back to Sanderson
he loses it and as the Calgary Flames come
home after a four-game road trip and win with a
dramatic third Perry four unanswered for a 6-3
victory